hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong we are back in
studio I am Mark Ellis as always Jaclyn
Coley is here and Jacqueline what a
flick we have to talk about we've been
holding off on talking about this movie
in order to get one guest in particular
there's many guests that probably saw
this movie in the theaters yeah when
they were kids everybody grew up playing
this video game upon which the movie's
based but there's one particular guest
that we needed to have that's why I'm
excited today yeah and I would say that
you know we were just waiting for this
moment for him that is that is the the
advertisement we're putting down but
we're just glad he's here it's happening
now late though it may be Mr Andre
Meadows joining us you know him better
as Black Nerd Comedy in all corners of
the interwebs you have a thriving
YouTube channel as we were talking about
before we went to air there's a lot of
other facets too being a personality
online now so you got all the Social
Media stuff doing Instagram doing Tick
Tock but black nerd comedies where you
can find Andre and all of his greatness
he celebrates movies guys remember we
used to do that yeah before we used to
tear movies down and dissect them like a
frog in Biology class Andre sort of puts
it all back together and reminds us why
we love celebrating this stuff in the
first place and our movie that we have
today Andre 101 to celebrate
trust the fungus trust the fungus you're
gonna you're gonna have to uh to take
some magic mushrooms here and hopefully
they give you some some fire some Stars
some growth and that is of course Super
Mario Brothers from
1993 we are obviously doing this in
anticipation of the Super Mario Brothers
movie which comes out as of this
recording I think it's either out last
night or tonight so that movie is from
illumination and that is 100 entirely
animated so get a lot of great vocal
Town everybody's looking forward to this
movie this could be like a billion
dollar plus grocer yeah but not
necessarily similar to the 1993 version
which was called Super Mario Brothers
and I would say Loosely based on the
video games that they had at the time
yes the movie didn't quite do with the
box office would I think this new one is
gonna be but we're gonna get into that
and I also want to give an editorial
shout out on our website right now
rottentomatoes.com you can check out 10
awesome video games that were made into
terrible movies so you got your Hitman
on there you got your Mortal Kombat
Annihilation on there what are they just
tense
no it's the truly terrible not not
questionable not bad we're not we're not
even any Assassin's Creed's territory on
this one we're talking the worst of the
worst the second Tomb Raider
okay like I think Max Payne might be on
that list somewhere because I mean again
Super Mario Bros and we'll talk about it
once we get into the movie talk segment
but like I think that there's some fun
to be had if for no other reason the
Nostalgia of even this movie kind of
reminds you just how movies were made
how products were turned into how other
source material was adapted into films
back when we were all so very young we
also have 49 video game movies ranked by
the Tomato Meter that's an another
article you can click on on the site
werewolves within is currently number
one
2021. Super Mario Brothers I mean it's
hanging in there at number 21 so it's
still that's sad look if your AP Top 25
that's good in college basketball it may
not be quite as shiny according to the
tomatoes student you know that's still
passing right you will get out of
college on that one honestly
you shouldn't go
stay home all right now Jacqueline has
to really get her PhD on here because
before we get to two minutes with Tim
and then we're going to talk with Andre
about what's going on with him and all
this Super Mario Brothers greatness and
I say that in quotes Jacqueline what we
do on this show sometimes we drifted
away from it occasionally because we've
been covering some like super popular
movies or sets of movies that everybody
knows and loves we're gonna do a
synopsis today simply because I don't
have to be the one that does it so I'm
gonna go ahead and toss you the ball and
ask you this question I've been dying to
ask you since we started since I met you
I can't wait to hear this Jacqueline
what is the 1993 Super Mario Brothers
movie about go first of all as we say
D's get degrees be prepared for a d plus
synopsis I know this is the grade I'm
getting going into it and I'm gonna rise
to that occasion listen it's past fail
with the synopsis yes really I was going
with the D in The Better Homes
passville I'm questionable listen so
we're taking ourselves back to New York
of the 1990s ladies and gentlemen this
is a dirtier New York before Giuliani
cleaned it up definitely before Giuliani
cleaned it up this is the this is more
than New York of coming to America so it
is dirty it is dingier well it turns out
way way way long time ago 65 million
years ago there was a meteorite that hit
that very spot and it actually made two
separate Dimensions that overlay on top
of each other in New York there is the
one that had like dinosaur-like things
and then there's the New York that we
get to know and they both developed
alongside each other eventually we find
our two plumbers Luigi Mario and Mario
Mario they are brothers they are
bickering Mario is the older one Luigi
is the younger one played by the very
Hispanic John Leguizamo and the very
British Bob Hopkins but they are Italian
plumbers without Italian accents very
good New York accents though anyway they
have been tasked to figure out what is
going on with this fungus infestation
which is really what it seems like these
two worlds are beginning to melt they
come across this girl named Daisy who
seems very interested in this fungus and
they somehow get transported into the
dino Dimension and inside the dino
Dimension they find Koopa all of his
crazy Minions he is the mayor leader of
this separate Dimension and they are
trying to invade into the modern human
world they were all evolved from
dinosaurs they were all evolved from
dinosaurs and now even though they have
some of the characteristics of dinosaurs
they look like humans that is played by
Dennis Hopper all kinds of hijinks ensue
they eventually come to realize that the
fungus is trying to help them it's
because the fungus is actually the king
been melded into a fungus they figure
out a way to undo that and everyone
lives happily ever after there's a
romance somewhere in between there
between Daisy and Luigi which is awkward
and silly oh and Daisy studies the
fungus
that is what happened ladies and
gentlemen but I just want to go ahead
and say that the only reason why I'm
also doing this is because y'all can't
even watch it because if anybody wanted
to go watch this movie right now you
better get to eBay
oh did Andre bring we gotta go physical
media with him
yeah that's it can I hold the DVD in my
hand real quick this is classic Andre
brought this in I watched this movie in
pieces on YouTube and this is just the
Washington Post says it's a blast who
said that the Washington Post who said
that a very reputable newspaper that was
not in Horn today I want to see who
wrote that may or may not be owned by a
future owner of the Washington Commander
so that's very exciting it is also
eye-popping special effects yeah there's
another good the 60 second preview you
know this was back in the time when they
used to have fakes reviews no you're not
accusing Super Mario Brothers how much
you want to bet it says like when Tim
comes in there I bet it says it's a
blast if you want to die
how much you want to bet that that's
what this really is there's an
exclamation point that is the end of a
sentence
ax is a perfect transition to our next
segment because we're about to throw it
over to our buddy Tim Ryan who's going
to tell us what the critics like the
Washington Post like 60 second preview
we're saying about Super Mario Brothers
when it was released in 1993 Tim is of
course our expert review curation
manager here at Rotten Tomatoes so Tim
you only got two minutes good luck two
means with Tim Once video games became
big business it was inevitable that
Hollywood would attempt to cash in but
one of the immediate problems was how do
you craft a narrative out of something
that is essentially narrative free and
by imposing such narrative aren't you
taking away what's special about the
games so in the 1982 Pac-Man cartoon
series The titular hero was a working
stiff with a wife and kid and on
Saturday Super Kid the following year
Frogger was a reporter and Donkey Kong
was on the lamb after escaping from the
circus at least Pitfall Harry actually
explored jungles like he did in the game
ironically while Super Mario Brothers
had a slightly more defined narrative
than those other games when it came time
to make the movie there was even greater
disagreement over what it should be like
the Super Mario Brothers movie was what
can politely be described as a troubled
production
it had multiple scripts arguments over
whether it was a movie for kids or a
dark satire Stars Bob Hoskins and John
Leguizamo drinking on set and lots of
finger pointing when it flopped
it's developed something of a cult
following in the ensuing years but
critics and audiences were roundly
disappointed upon its release feeling it
lacked what made the game special while
also not working on its own
Super Mario Brothers is rotten at 29 on
the Tomato Meter with 42 reviews and it
has a 29 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Stephen Hunter of the
Baltimore Sun wrote devotees of the game
May derive some pleasure from seeing its
obstacles given quasi-flash and set in
motion but that inert pleasure soon
pales in a torrent of none too special
effects confusing storylines and
characters without personalities
however in a fresh review Roger Hurlburt
of the South Florida Sun Sentinel wrote
bizarre replete and often stunning
special effects and very strange from
the outset Super Mario Brothers is
curiously entertaining even though it
often makes little sense
so that's Super Mario Brothers and if
you require further listening check out
our episode on video game movies and
we've also got one episode each for two
different Mortal Kombat movies back to
you folks that drinking story is
actually true so well we'll talk about
that and a whole lot of other things
thank you so much Tim I also have the
full review from The Washington Post Hal
Henson is who said it's a blast and
that's what's on the DVD cover house
full review or at least a fuller snippet
says this movie which was directed by
music video Wiz Kids Rocky Morton and
Annabelle jenko is sweet and funny and
full of bright invention in short it's a
blast yeah he was sincere he doesn't
write anymore
that was it that was a swan song I
didn't say that I just said he doesn't
write anymore let you determine what
that means in short the question that we
always ask of our guests here Andre
Meadows you're up is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong about Super Mario Brothers from
1993 which is 29 nine percent well first
you have to give credit this is probably
one of the few times where the critics
and audience score is literally exactly
the same so it is at 29 you're always on
aligned with some things so I say to all
of you that yes you are wrong right
right tomatoes is wrong the audience is
wrong I'm not saying it needs to be a
whole lot higher but I just think 29 is
a little it's a little because because
there are definitely some things in this
movie that given given what is in this
movie even with all the troubles
production and given when it came out
and what movies were like at that time I
think yeah I think it should be a little
bit higher and I think there's still
some things about Super Mario Brothers I
like about that that I would like to see
even some movies of today so okay so
it's it's too low for Andre Meadows
Jacqueline Coley 29 as Andre intimated
with both the critics and the audiences
did everybody get it wrong I feel bad
like I invited you here and I'm just
gonna rip on this movie because it's
awful it's but it's like the room
level in its stupidity I I'm literally
like oh my god get stoned and watched it
well see that's amazing that's where
we're that's where we're in degree like
it's it's one of those like it's I'm
never gonna say it's a good movie but
I'm going to say that from an
entertainment perspective it is it is a
very entertaining movie and it's one of
those movies where I can kind of see
what they were trying to go with but
then of course you have the multiple
scripts and the drinking in there so the
reason why I say this is if you're
taking this movie seriously Rotten
Tomatoes is sober is a judge this should
be lower that's if you were saying as a
camp Masterpiece of stupidity and like
how did this get made and why does
everyone involved in it need to be
ashamed of it
yes this is we this is certified fresh
this is the greatest movie ever made if
it's if it begins if you look at this
movie and are like I want to make sure
everyone involved in it doesn't go to
film school yes like legitimately sure
everybody comes out of this smelling
horrible you know what I mean if you
want to Revel in how awful this is and
even celebrate in the Ridiculousness of
it to where it became iconic we are here
okay so you try to tell me anything
other than that I will hit you I think
there's a little bit of a middle ground
if you're gonna go from this movie be
extremely horrible like comparing it to
the room so the room is different but
only based on budget the the delusion
that allowed them to make the room
allowed them to make this you also had a
big difference we'll talk about in movie
talk between the room and this I'm going
to say Rotten Tomatoes a pottery
watching it I'm gonna say 29 I'm not
gonna like protest I'm gonna like make a
sign and like stand outside come on I'm
gonna be well I can get this to the 30s
I can get this to the 35 percentile I
think you just need to be in some that's
why you want to put it in the 30s that's
why we're going to talk about it right
now with our movie talk segment hit the
music Brian
[Music]
so before we even get to the movie when
did Super Mario Brothers when did the
Nintendo Entertainment System first
enter our lives I we were like the last
family on the Block to get a Nintendo
but back in the day you could go to a
video store and you could rent the
entire Nintendo system yeah so we rented
it a couple times have like a test drive
with this thing and I remember like we
play Super Mario Brothers and duck hunt
and it was just like this is the most
Revel I'm never going outside again this
is so exciting and then two days later
you gotta take it back to the video
store one day my dad came home this is
shortly before we moved from Columbia
Maryland to Virginia when he got out of
the service and he had the Nintendo with
them and we lost our minds and we just
played Super Mario Brothers that entire
summer till we moved and then we played
it once we got to Virginia instead of
making friends so it was very exciting
to hear that there was a Super Mario
Brothers movie that was going to be
coming out but again Andre you're our
guest when you first stumbled upon the
Nintendo Entertainment System and our
beloved brothers who are plumbers where
were you what was going on well yeah
Nintendo was kind of like the level of
how you made friends forever quite some
time because if you're in the
neighborhood you had a Nintendo
everybody wanted to go hang out at your
place the more games you had the more
friends you would want to have to come
over and it was one of those things of
like it really became it became like the
star Billy Sneetches and like are you an
intent you're a kid to have a Nintendo
or don't have one and your friendship
matter with that so it was like it was
something that everybody on the Block
want to have and I remember finally
getting mine Christmas morning my
parents you know how sometimes how old
are you oh old enough
I mean what Christmas was it like that
you gotta be Christmas uh like I'm just
trying to picture the age you were like
87.88 it was when the action said
because there was like the original
Nintendo robbed the robot but then they
had the action set with the zapper and
Mario Brothers so we're talking maybe an
eight nine year old so yeah so what
happened fairly early in Nintendo's
matriculation we were going over to
Andre's house yeah well no but we'll get
there yeah
8089 so that was the thing it was like
when you got that system it was like
such a such a like an extra rate of
Passage to now having that and I
remember you also I had those parents
that was like oh you're not getting that
that cost too much money yeah you were
not getting into this house you got an
Atari you're good you know so so but
then the course is that one Christmas or
like all right we went out to Toys R Us
last minute they were happy to be one on
the Shelf so we hooked you up you know
and then so that was what sort of the
beginning of it but like that was it was
the system that kind of started it but
then like that's when the obsession came
in yeah because it was like then you got
Super Mario Brothers two then you got
Nintendo Power Magazine coming in the
mailbox then you got the Super Mario
Brothers Super Show cartoon coming on
and all of this and then Super Nintendo
with Super Mario World after Mario 2 and
Mario three and then this All Leads up
to this movie and so at this point I am
so in the Mario cult like I am so like
ready for anything Mario gives me that
when I see this movie's coming out even
with everything you've shown to me of
like this ain't the literacy in the
movie this ain't no game I'm still like
I'm ready I'm ready to do this and saw
it day one when it opened and so it a
couple more times in the theater because
I don't know if everyone remembers these
it used to be the dollar theater yeah oh
yeah after the short run and Mario
Brothers we have the dollar theater
they're still around a little bit Yeah
Yeah but like you know Mario Brothers
run was a little short
there's a movie that came out a couple
weeks after Super Mario Brothers that
sort of ended every other theatrical run
up to that point with Dinosaurs on top
of that it did have dinosaurs yeah Mario
had the dinosaurs first Yeah by a couple
weeks yeah yeah a little movie called
Jurassic Park came out yeah I know you
have to because I think they said
something about like I think some people
that worked on Jurassic Park actually
saw the Yoshi that's in Super Mario
Brothers and you could just imagine them
being like Oh that's that's cute nice
try that's very adorable I doing
something with Dinosaurs too we'll let
you see it in a couple weeks but what's
really funny is before these movies
happened in this town they were both
thought to be the same they were both
thought to be like a level of like
potential yeah and then when you have
Mario as the character as big as Mario
was of course it's like oh yeah this is
going to be the oh going into the summer
yeah you look at you look at Jurassic
Park and Super Mario Brothers as
tentpole and obviously even though
Michael Crichton had written Jurassic
Park everybody knew who Mario was
everybody walking on the street it was
just it was almost like by the 90s new
babies that were born just had that you
know how like like kids are born but
they they just kind of know who
Chewbacca is right they know what the
Beatles are it's like you knew who Mario
was and so you knew that there was going
to be this movie coming out you knew who
Mario was Jaclyn because you also
apparently had a Nintendo yeah before I
did yeah so I was a product I was a
child of divorce and generational trauma
so we were buying affection three gifts
in my household I had a divorced dad and
different stay grandparents that didn't
want to be alienated and a new stepdad
that was very happy to get my attention
so yeah I had a Mario at 89. I had a
Sega baby I was gonna say it but I bet
you were an early childhood I had an
early Genesis kid I was an early
Microsoft kid and like again I was an
only child it wasn't like y'all though
because again I was the girl that wanted
to play these games so like I was
playing the girly games by myself boys
were the only ones that could do that
sort of thing and I will admit my Mario
stuff was limited like I did Mario for
sure remember Mickey's Clubhouse that
Nintendo game I was like underrated
Mickey Mouse campaign yeah like that one
where it was like the adventure oh my
God Castlevania all of the RPGs where it
was just you and you just go long term
but I would say uh Mario was not as good
because everybody liked to play Mario in
teams everybody liked to play like Luigi
Mario you die you go you die you go yeah
oh yeah I I always let my brother my
little brother be Mario because I was
rooting for him to perish and so I could
be Luigi yeah
Sports terms I was rooted for the
underdog yeah so I wanted to be Luigi
like the brother who the princess is not
expecting to show up she's like oh it's
you yeah I'm like yeah Mario died I'm
here but that's the difference too with
even Sega like they had that with Sonic
and Tails but everyone just wanted to be
Sonic it was just about you and your
solo Adventure way more than it was
about the other ones anyway the whole
point is yeah so I definitely had an
early Mario but yeah switched over to
Sega very very early so literally NES is
the only one I have I never had a 64. I
never had I stopped see we got Sega
Genesis late in the game too and so by
then Super Nintendo was already cropping
up and I remember uh it's still very
good friends to this day the Whitehead
family they had a Super Nintendo early
and I think me and my brother were just
like we just kind of we didn't even want
a Super Nintendo for the longest time
we're like no we're good with Sega
Genesis we got altered bees we got
golden ax yeah good and then we just
kept going over the whiteheads to play
like the Super Mario World and we're
like this is a really nice if you had if
you had siblings Super Mario NES was the
perfect one because they had the four
controller click in and that literally
like changed the game because then you
could play four player and that that was
really it for me yeah so then the movie
comes and it almost seems like around
this time in Hollywood and going back to
the 80s too it's almost like Studios be
grudgingly made these movies based on
other properties like well he-man's
really popular we gotta have a He-Man
movie yeah Super Mario bro this is
really I guess we gotta have a Super
Mario we'll see but but about that
though so something I find very
interesting about that time and I think
this will explain because the big
question people always ask especially
that is like why did Super Mario
Brothers this bright colorful Mushroom
Kingdom Pepe music everything turns into
Blade Runner Jr but facts I think you
have to I think you have to look at that
path because before you'll probably
remember this like Transformers the
movie GI Joe the movie you know like a
lot of the movies were very much let's
just take the cartoon or let's just say
the thing and just extend it just make
it longer like 90 minutes right but then
Batman comes along and Batman was very
much Batman at that time unless you were
like a hardcore comic person was very
much okay it's it's Adam West the reruns
of that show or it's Super Friends the
cartoon and then this Tim Burton movie
comes along and it's all dark you know
at the time and like Keaton playing
Batman and it's taking like a different
level than what we've ever seen Batman
and you felt the streets and and the
dirt yeah in Gotham City exactly and
then after that Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles comes out and this again is that
for the comic books you react this wacky
cartoon with these four turtles eating
pizzas yelling Cowabunga and now here's
this movie where they're live action and
they're dark you know darks and it's got
this more serious tone more into the
comics you felt the sword you felt the
sewer right you know then you got The
Addams Family coming out and The Adams
Family even though that was always kind
of in that darker tone but it was still
a wacky sitcom but now you've got this
little bit edgier it's PG-13 there's
blood and references yeah it was early
90s it was like early 90s was very gothy
very sort of like you know yeah yeah
that you have dick Trace
so I feel like that's what happened with
Super Mario Brothers I could see because
there's even like reports that say that
Nintendo was very aware that they wanted
to make something a little bit edgier
maybe this wasn't exactly what they
wanted but there was this sort of
concept of let's take these classic
properties and do something a little bit
edgier and more you know more all
audiences with it all ages with it
because that will justify it being in
the movies especially when you have like
even with Mario you have the Super Mario
Bros Super Show which is like you had
live action Mario and Luigi with Captain
Lou Albano and daddy Wells how do you
make the movie look different and so I
could see them wanting to do that it's
just the process of getting there that's
a very weird link very weird thing and
then also think I think what's
interesting with it too is if you really
look at it as much as it's
ridiculousness it's the splitting of the
difference they also still made a camp
movie right and and that was the part
two which I thought was interesting if
you look at the two I consider only
performances within it that work which
is Dennis Hopper and Bob Hopkins Bob
Hopkins again British man playing
Italian plumber didn't think it would
work as well as it does but it does work
like I made the joke about the Eddie
Valiant in he did he did I think it was
a stroke of casting genius the atheistic
aside because Bob Hoskins was everybody
even if like kids didn't know his name
you everybody saw Who Framed Roger
Rabbit which he started as another dark
one another one the advantage he had as
Eddie Valley and a is that him and his
co-star Roger couldn't do whiskey shots
in between takes but Kim and John like
uzamo did on this movie
not in the movie but then he like over
there
yeah so I think every kid just kind of
knew oh this is an adult I trust right
yeah and then you have what like again
John Leguizamo the perfect sort of
companion to him playing that Underdog
role he's he's maybe not quite as street
smart as his much older brother who
isn't really related by blood he just
kind of no the casting wasn't bad yeah
except for it's a it's a hype in the
sense of like these would not be the
people I would think of especially when
you think of again Italian I could just
if I was an Italian I'd be livid like
let's be real like I'm pretty sure De
Niro and Pacino said no you know yeah
but then when you look at although
pescia's King Koopa would have been
pretty fun but but so that point he's
doing Eddie Valen he's doing the
straight man in a camp movie sort of
performance so well and then Hopper is
just giving sheriff and Nottingham real
name is
is just he is giving face and body and
he is just living his life with this
thing but that's the problem these two
guys are selling something that doesn't
work when you put it next to each other
like you can't have that be humans it
worked when it was Hopkins and it was
cartoons and it'll work with Dennis
Hopper if everybody else is in on the
joke yeah but you can't have these two
very Earnest performances that are in
such contrast to themselves and even the
world around them well that that is
obviously and there's like there's been
different articles and retrospections
about about that was one of the
challenges with this movie was that
there were so many different versions of
this movie and they all lean from it
being dark because that was what some of
the directors and original producers
wanted to it being lighter because it's
Disney slash Hollywood pictures getting
involved in there were different writers
and even the script that the cast got
when they got there was not the first
script that they got when they when they
signed up and so yeah so that's what's
so interesting to watch this movie
because you can tell like you can almost
see the different color pages of script
when you you're watching it because
you're like okay that doesn't seem to
connect with this and then there's
anything that with that and you know in
in tradition of many Cuts nowadays
there's also a longer cut of the movie
that got released there's a group called
The Super Mario Brothers movie archive
who we've been getting like interviews
and all these like old things that we
haven't seen from this movie and they
found like a longer version of this it's
not like time codes and stuff on it but
like it fills in some of the gaps that
were that in the movie or from the
novelization that I may or may not have
read
have the novelization of Willow oh nice
yeah yeah I think Willow is a little
more appreciated his Fine Art than the
Super Mario Brothers four tells a
different tale sir I'm I'm surprised
that the Super Mario Brothers movie got
anything more than like that those
sticker books that you had when you flip
through and just like put the sticker
where it belongs and it seems like when
you're watching this movie all the
stickers got jumbled up yeah but see but
that's the one thing I will defend about
this movie because look I I can
understand people talking about it being
bad or Being Cheesy or whatever but
especially in this very nostalgic you
know let's reboot everything let's think
about everything I'm not gonna name any
names but there's definitely some movies
that are now being put at like a high
regard that I kind of look on the same
level of least cheesiness if not they
could be better made but at least from
the cheese Camp Factor alone fat eggs
yeah Super Mario Brothers is like right
there I think what always just brings it
down is that it's an app Nation
adaptation of Mario if you were to be
like man there was this movie I used to
rip back in the day the VHS where there
were two Dimensions where one side was
dinosaurs if it was orgasm
Parker Matt Stone like low budget random
movies like if it had that like Napoleon
Dynamite Indie budget to it you're right
yeah it would have a totally different
that's one of the things that producer
Brian and I were talking as all boys do
we make great points when we're in the
bathroom together and we were talking
about how this movie is so more
watchable if you're not comparing it to
the video game it's just this random
movie where it's just made for kids I
actually really appreciate the the
two-dimensional thing I think that's a
cool the meter right they killed all the
dinosaurs yeah they do mention 65
million years ago which nobody knew that
65 Million number until it was on the
Jurassic Park poster so good on you
doing your research Super Mario too it
hits Earth and it creates this alternate
Dimension I think that is a really cool
premise and I think that the movie does
a Salient job of even for the kids
spelling out that there's this different
world that's sort of below our world and
the the like the Blade Runner thing you
talk about where it's like the different
version of Manhattan yeah Dino Hatton
and people eating like hot dogs that are
made out of bugs bugs it's like this
cool thing yeah oh these people are
aware that they that they desperately
want to get somewhere else yeah they
show it right in the beginning of the
movie it was like they're human looking
but yet they still hatch from eggs as
Daisy does the lady pushing the lady
she's like get your hands off my baby
yeah and everything's like all electric
based yeah around like all the cars and
stuff like that so yeah but yeah but it
is it is one of those weird things of
like but there there was clearly these
sort of Darker more adult tones that
they try to clean up with like a score I
think put that Allen's investor score in
there
and you're like no I mean that's
like why do they call Alan Silvestri for
cheesiness like he's done so many cheesy
movies I think just his favors like he's
got a few like of like he's a Judge
Dread yeah he's a nice guy he's a nice
guy I mean he also did Back to the
Future and his score is criminally
underrated for Young Guns too but
basically because he did Back to the
Future and he's proven that he can
really underscore these very poppy video
game moments um they keep calling him
don't get me wrong I love the Ready
Player One soundtrack but I almost like
Alice Silvestri Is Not Gonna Save Your
movie you know what I mean like the gods
will not save me that's what they were
trying though um the one thing I will
say about this is because I think when
it comes to video game movies and why we
have these terrible lists is one thing
we can very much appreciate having
watched shows like the last of us having
watched the early days of The Walking
Dead having watched the early days of
Game of Thrones when you have people who
at least respect the material or at
least respect the person who made the
material enough to be respectful of the
material as they adapt it no matter what
happens
I don't know I just find like it doesn't
go as far off the rails as the people
who clearly are not does that make sense
like this is an example of the people
who were making it didn't like it they
didn't care they didn't like it enough
to be to even try to come up with a good
idea for how to be both faithful to it
and then also expand it I feel like the
makers of this film and I don't want to
put it just on the directors I think
that this is this is Studio heads on
down looked at this property and looked
at this movie they're making with that
same eyes that even I do sometimes in my
adulthood where I'm like oh that's four
kids yeah so like like you see anything
animated and you just have that initial
like oh okay it's animated it's for kids
it's not and animation is not just for
children but when you look at Super
Mario Brothers I think the studio at the
time was like this is just for kids kids
will just lap anything up as long as we
put a familiar skin on it and that's the
difference between this and something
like the last of us where the care and
sort of making sure that you're honoring
the The Source material was was it was a
factor in every step of the process as
opposed to this Andre where it feels
like where the the moments where they
said oh we need to make this more like
Mario maybe in post-production let's
just add the sound effect let's just do
this that's where the movie falters well
it's funny because like I said I I think
part of it is also and I always try to
go back to the time that it was made
because at the time and we know so much
about Mario now from his various games
but at the time you had the three
Nintendo games you had the Super Mario
World and there is definitely some lore
in there but definitely not to level
that we have at the time also I can't
help but to feel like there's there at
least at that time there was a little
bit of like this is popular but how long
is going to last because we just came
out of the video game Crash of the 80s
and yet Nintendo brings it back but
there is there's probably still that
feeling at that time until we got
Genesis and yeah this is Mike they felt
like they were making a pet rock movie
more than they felt that they were
making franchise yeah yeah of course now
looking back it's like of course this is
going to last forever but who knows but
but even even still like I said because
they were trying to go with that weird
like darkish tone like they do with some
of these other movies it is still
interesting to see how they incorporate
certain things like if you look
throughout Dino hat there's like a big
sweeping shot you can look at some of
the buildings and like there's a shop
named Hammer Brothers there's one named
Bullet Bill I mean even the shoes that
they wear the the they incorporate the
jumping with these really cool boots
which you know talk about the movie but
if the daily River released those boots
it's actual shoes to buy sneaker heads
would buy those up immediately there'd
be a line around the block so so they
you know they figure out a way to do the
jumping and then putting bullet bills in
that you know so they figured out all
these different ways to use at least the
names and the properties of it I mean
you have Koopa is President Koopa as
opposed to King Koopa uh but you know
you have all these different ways that
they did incorporate it they even found
a way to do the colors of Mario and
Luigi towards the end you know it's just
they're variations of how they do them
like with Google they gave you the
colors that is faithful yeah yeah
that's something that's still something
compared to some like I said describe to
something they named it Super Mario
Brothers that's something too they're
still plumbers
because at that time that was that was
something I mean like I said it's very
at that time you know what you know at
that time that was something but yeah
did you walk out of the theater in 93
when you saw this movie for the first
time did you say oh that was a good move
I need to see it again
because I I think that's and that's why
I do get into this about when you look
at things more critically nowadays I
think there was something there was a
Vibe at least in my circle there was a
Vibe of like we felt the edginess of
this compared to the video game and that
was I think we actually like we were
right at that age of like can't watch
The Rated R stuff yet but a little bit
too old for some of the younger stuff
but this is like one of those things of
like like how I feel about this is
probably how like some kid felt when
they saw the first Transformer movie
where it's just like oh this is
different and we're looking like this is
not like the cartoon but they were
probably like oh this is different from
the cartoon that's how sometimes I feel
about that with Mario is like this felt
like something that was like ooh it's
Mario but when did the first
Transformers come out 2000 yeah yeah but
that was laptop High School yeah yeah
but that's something I just I just it
just had this different vibe to it and
especially for someone like myself who
watched who literally watched like the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show and
seeing that version of it was very goofy
very comical you know like it just it
just had this different vibe to it and
having grown up watching uh like I said
a little movie like Batman Ninja Turtles
and family and all that it felt like it
was in that vein that at the time I
didn't even take into the account like
oh this is bad or this is not super
faithful it was just like I saw Mario I
saw Luigi I saw some things reference I
saw there's a woman named Bertha and I
know that's a fish from Mario 3. you
know I know that the garbage men are
Snippets yeah toad is in there there's
an interesting point you bring up though
with just being a kid and and seeing
your characters that again if you're a
kid you're just buying into this is
Martin Luigi yeah and seeing them just
act differently than they did in the
game they were actually real people yeah
in this one to a certain extent because
in the game your your quest is to rescue
this princess right but it's such a
banana like you it's like oh thank you
Mario you're my hero but you never
really when you see John Leguizamo
actually like be like smitten with Daisy
and he's like asking around they like go
on this awkward like double date yeah
kind of like oh this is what adults do
like I'm growing up I'm I'm hitting
puberty as I'm watching this movie
because they're plumbers and they're and
they're video game characters but
they're real people and they have real
needs Jacqueline yeah that's why they
made the Goombas dance
that's right because they're they're
evil but they have a little bit of a
heart and something
I
love it the Goombas dancing
they're loyal and and stupid as Koopa
says in there but yes they're in the
elevator they're wearing the iconic
outfits now and they're trapped in the
elevator with Goombas and so to try to
distract them there's a little song
playing in the background and so they
just sway Luigi starts swaying the
Goombas and then they just start to
dance and it's just
moment with the
smarted literally their biggest foe yeah
with the power of Swing well they're not
you know they're like too bright and
it's a very cute elevator scene it's
like it's like the Ninja Turtles uh the
the bay Turtle scene where they're in
the elevator doing a little hip-hop so
I'm gonna let you have this one and the
road chip but but yeah but but there is
something I do want to give
um I will I do have to give this movie I
think this is something that I do have
to give credit for with the movie even
compared to movies today and that is the
production of this movie like just the
design of this movie and how even if it
looks dirty even it looks dirty just how
real it feels like something I saw
someone mention this in a YouTube video
talking about the movie but I didn't
even realize it there's a part where
Koopa isn't like his like his office and
you can see from his window the actual
set of Dino hat and like from his window
it is like the legit set they were on
earlier and just like feeling that depth
is really cool because it's like you
know especially nowadays with a lot of
things being CG uh even the backgrounds
and everything like it's nice to see
that they did go to North Carolina and
make this entire Dino hat and be like a
real place and put all these people in
it so that way when you're seeing them
running through this you feel that that
grunginess sometimes of them going
through Dino Hatton I thought that the
the Dennis Hopper as Cooper I thought
that was a stroke of casting genius yeah
and I'll tell you why it's because it
remind me of the same way that the Sonic
movies cast Jim Carrey as Dr Robotnik
because if you are a parent and you're
taking kids to see this movie you know
who Dennis Hopper is you've seen Dennis
Hopper for a decade you've seen him in
stuff like easy right like you know this
guy this guy's an actor okay so he's at
least somebody that you can go on to and
I will say his performance without
getting too political reminds me of
somebody who you may have seen in the
news
it's almost like Trump saw this movie
just like that's the guy I gotta be and
the germaphobe as well and it was
honestly the best part about it it was
so Earnest like I said Sheriff of
Nottingham realness like I mean he was
really about it I just remember being in
this movie and this is before like you
walk in you know what the running time
and all that stuff is I do remember like
wondering okay I get what you're doing
here I didn't think the movie was good
when I saw in the theater and I remember
being like how much longer we got to be
here because I do want to go home and
watch and play Super Mario Brothers like
at least made me want to play the game
again but I also remember this movie not
really spelling out two that we're
getting towards a conclusion or like
we're just we it just kind of felt like
we're just keep existing in this world
for a long time so I remember feeling
the length of this movie and it maybe
felt longer than the actual run time was
well then you should watch the
director's Cup oh yeah because he needs
that right he needs that look yeah but
yeah I do definitely agree that like you
know even again with the script changes
and everything that probably muddled it
up a little bit but yeah I do I do agree
that like there's a really good story
element in this and then going back to
Dennis Hopper's performance is something
I didn't even notice so recently because
they talk about how they are they're
evolved from dinosaurs and so with uh
Dennis Hopper king cooper he's evolved
from the Tyrannosaurus Rex I didn't know
this until recently he constantly has
like his arms like close to him kind of
like T-Rex arms when he's talking and
stuff and so I was like oh that's a
really neat little thing posture of the
Maybe person have you noticed how that
said that like
yeah yeah very true very true the
posture of the Maybe person
I live from this show I I live I live on
this internet and I will not pretend
that I don't yeah maybe person well like
yeah I will say this and and this goes
back to like my love of sports is that
you you watch a season right and you can
more often than not point to when a team
lost a critical game and then they go on
a run and it's like oh maybe that was
the turning point this was not
necessarily the Turning Point yet for
video game movies because for every good
one that we got like Mortal Kombat 95 we
got it seems like a dozen bad ones but
Mortal Kombat is I I love Mortal Kombat
absolutely right but there's cheesiness
in that as well certainly but that one
it felt like the source material was
more naturally ingrained we were into
well they based it off of as much as
they could off of the actual right
because the Super Mario Brothers game
arguably gave you more story than you
got with a Mortal Kombat game but they
still pulled something out of it but now
we actually look forward to video game
movies especially something like this
new the Super Mario Brothers Super Mario
Bros the movie because it feels like we
know how to do it and I think the world
animation serves Mario so well because
it's more seamless for all the Utes that
are going to be going to this movie and
seeing like oh Mario looks like this and
the video game looks like this this is
just I now I just have less pressure on
me because I don't have the controller
like I think this movie coming out I
think this is going to be
gigantic I think it's going to be over a
billion dollars yeah but I think I said
I think that's also very telling my time
I think at that time when the 93 movie
came out it was this concept even like
you said with some of the creators it's
like well we don't want to just make the
game a live action and that's it like we
got to put our Edge on we gotta put our
spin on it because I'm the director I'm
the producer whatever right whereas I
feel like we are now in that era of The
Last of Us in this movie I'm just like
no we need to be as close to the source
material as possible ask Sonic
which that's still the one thing that I
always think about just completely
inside that was the turning point in
video game yes I think that was designed
no I think that no I think that's Sonic
going to the dentist Studios because the
director told them yeah the director was
like y'all are idiots and the director
was like this is stupid and the studio
told them granted this was in the messy
part of Paramount when they were still
trying to figure stuff out they were
dealing with Redmond the studio just
pushed ahead with their ideas and it
went so badly so quickly that they were
like you were right let's switch it over
and I think that switched in the sense
of like trust the Nerds the Nerds know
because they know what the angry effers
are gonna say if we don't get this
they're giving us a sneak preview on
Twitter as to how this movie's gonna be
received if we don't embrace it if we
like now I think studios are paying
attention to that to be like listen to
the Nerds the Nerds know and the Nerds
because there's been enough success to
where they have to listen up until that
point they'd kept messing it up enough
to where they didn't have to listen
right they've been interfering enough to
where certain things were successful and
certain things weren't again I still do
believe video game adaptations are hard
so don't hire the wrong team that's
where the studio messes up first but the
second part is if you hire the right
team listen to them yeah and then there
yeah there was no 93 or 90 through
Twitter for them to listen to How Mario
was coming up you probably would have
heard some of these things also just as
a side I am very very shocked maybe it
was because of Super Mario Brothers
failure I'm surprised we did not get
like a Sonic the Hedgehog movie of the
90s just of how big he was like but like
a like puppet like costume characters
they wanted to I think the same reasons
why because remember this actually had a
high water mark for a while this just
kind of like cleared the way for at
least five years before they really went
back into video and it's scarred
Nintendo for a generation yeah I mean
literally their properties to any sort
of big screen adaptation absolutely what
we had after this were like blank man
and like Meteor Man and like random
little superhero adaptations underrated
films in my opinion yes true but movies
that were not intended to be whatever
and that by the way Meteor Man and
Blankman guess what they gave Worth to
which changed it all and
[Laughter]
yes and steal but like but literally for
a long time they were just these B
movies that you would send to either um
crappy former um TV stars or uh
basketball basketball players athletes
whatever put them in a suit because they
have a built-in audience yeah
yeah I mean it still might have just
been Shaq walking around as an Orlando
Magic
Super Mario Brothers for what it's worth
I think that it did uh whether it
intended to do it this way or not it
shaped the future of video game movies
and it gave at least a starting point to
grow from and that's where we are now in
2023 with all these great video game
possibilities that we actually look
forward to we think we they could be
quality entertainment yeah and say what
you will about the campiness the
cheesiness the Badness or whatever about
Super Mario Brothers but I think there's
something to be said and I'm sure
Mario's involvement has a lot to do with
it but this is literally 30 years later
people are still talking about this
movie there's still videos about this
movie there's still discussion about the
movie there's no thoughts about this
movie when making another video game
adaptation and I don't know for me is
always I will always appreciate a way
out there movie that's wrong that I
remember over a safe movie that is
blanded I will forget the moment I
walked out of the theater is so that
movie it is so that even if you don't
like it you are not going to forget it
and there's something very special about
that and I think also even the weight of
the movie is made just even the process
of this movie because remember this was
a movie that major Studios want to do
and they went with an independent Studio
because they knew they would have a
little bit more control I guess or they
thought they did as well as you know
there's also like merchandising and
things like that but like even just that
concept of it like that's something we
don't see nowadays there's no way that
some like random like Indie studios are
gonna go I'm gonna take the biggest
property that you have and make a movie
out of it so yeah it's just some
interesting things about that movie
making that even though it went off the
rails there's a Fascination about it
that you would not see in movies now and
there's varying reports about how well
this movie did at the box office but
it's on its best day it might have
recouped its budget because the budget I
think was maybe like 40 million ish and
it might have gotten there worldwide but
they won it they obviously want this to
be a hit and then like they thought it
could be Jurassic Park yeah and then
Jurassic Park showed up
they thought it could be dressed how
excited are you for the for the new
Super Mario Brothers movie are you like
losing your mind I am very excited the
all the the animation like you said the
animation definitely lends itself to
this property and I think that what I
like about at least from what I've seen
so far is I love that they are
incorporating different references in a
very unique way like the score is a mix
of a movie score but with Super Mario
sounds in it they've actually made a
commercial fake commercial that uses the
theme song from the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show where the Mario brothers and
plumbers again unless we get all the
fame how you feeling about that voice
the voice is it's the typical thing it's
just it's like we get all the
celebrities to do the voices and you
know they're gonna do what they're gonna
do but it sounds like Charlie Day's
giving it a given a design
yeah
so so I think it's gonna I think I don't
I don't think that is going to be a
deterrent
um that's the realest thing you said
you're like I don't think that's gonna
be a deterrent and that is the only
thing about that you've been honest
no I'm very I'm very excited about this
movie I yeah I yes are there other
people I would have cast in some of
these parts absolutely but at the end of
the day I don't think that is going to
take away from from the movie and I
think that and I think the people they
got are going to give the best they're
going to be and just don't take a spike
away from my boy Sebastian Maniscalco
because yeah by the way though but
that's what I'm saying so I'm very also
excited for Anya because I want to see
her do voice because I've always said
that she does amazing face which means
that I think she does really great
non-verbal acting like she does really
great like split the reason why that
movie works is because you see
everything working out on her face as we
just watch this dude go insane so I'll
be very interested to see how she is
just a vocal performance yes and just as
I have to giving though again Yoshi the
Yoshi in there yeah it's super cute and
no Again upstaged by a big T-Rex a few
weeks later but I thought at the time
that animatronic that Yoshi was very
very adorable there's a lot of things to
like about this movie as insane this
movie is and the fact that this cast
with all that was going on with it gave
their all as best they could I think
jealous and Bob Hoskins had good
chemistry yeah if it's at least worth a
watch one time all right so Andre Meadow
says it's a blast let's hit that music
it transition
foreign
if I make you president Koopa of
entertainment right do you release this
movie like on streaming services I I
think it's kind of cool that you it's
hard to get I wanna I wanna I know I
wanna full on like 30th Anniversary but
like like a 30th Anniversary release but
like No Holds Barred like tell all the
stories tell how insane it was like
we're we're okay with it we'll put the
little disclaimer the opinions of
whatever it's not match the studio it
would just let it all out I think people
would appreciate that I wouldn't hate
like a three-part documentary about the
making oh this is this has yeah this has
documented like streaming documentary
written all over it I would not hate it
uh what I loved is having you finally in
studio Andre it was so great we've been
talking about you being on the show for
you know there's so many properties
whether it's Ninja Turtles or sonic that
that you celebrate online but having you
here for Super Mario Brothers this is
like sort of the culmination I mean it
was definitely not bad having the wiki
uh article literally sitting across for
us oh my God oh my God I also have this
is the this is not the novelization but
this is like the behind the scenes
microchips to movie stars movie stars oh
my god wow as official art from the
movie and everything and behind the
scenes nerd I love this movie I'm I
don't say that as a disc that was a
compliment no no absolutely that's how
he's doing Black Nerd Comedy wherever
you enjoy your online Endeavors uh what
you got going on you got stuff coming
out I'm sure you're probably going to be
doing some stuff covering the release of
Super Mario Brothers the movie yeah
we'll definitely check out the Super
Mario Brothers movie and whatever movies
I'm I'm excited this is a very
interesting time for me because it's
like I actually was in the theater not
too long ago and the trailer for The
Super Mario Bros movie came up and then
immediately after was a trailer for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mayhem and
I'm just like I am living my best life
you should do that like I did the video
and be like it's me Seasons you know
what I mean Power Rangers is back with a
30th Anniversary Special I'm like yeah
this is you know it it took long enough
it took long and you earned it up to
Marvel in DC all you want to that's fun
but I over here it is Mario it is Power
Rangers it is Sonic it is Spiderman in
the spider-verse and it is Ninja Turtles
oh just check out Andre again black dirt
comedy wherever you enjoy going online
uh YouTube's probably a great hub for
that and he just when you're watching
he's funny endearing makes you feel like
a kid and celebrate all this stuff that
we love once upon a time and can still
love well into adulthood uh for this
show rate subscribe to all that great
stuff that you love doing wherever you
listen to us or watch us do whatever
that platform encourages you for uh our
special guest Andre Blackbird comedy
Meadows Jacqueline Coley producer Brian
remsens hanging out here with us I am
Millie Mark Ellis and the whole gang
here at Rotten Tomatoes thanks for
watching we'll see you next week and
we're sorry Mario your princess is in
another Castle
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]